hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm and today we're talking
about something mathematical it relates
to fitness but it has applications far
beyond it as well and that is the law of
truly large numbers the most typical
formulation of the law of truly large
numbers is that if it is possible for
something to happen no matter how remote
those possibilities are if it has enough
opportunities to happen the odds of it
actually happening converge on a
certainty so just a just an easy
illustration of that if something has a
one in a thousand chance of happening so
in any one opportunity for it to happen
there's a one in a thousand chance of it
happening 0.1% if that very very vent
had a thousand opportunities to happen
than the chance of it actually occurring
on one of those opportunities is about
63.2%
so there's basically a two-thirds chance
of it happening even though in each
individual opportunity there was one
tenth of one percent of a chance of it
happening so like I said this absolutely
applies when you're talking about
fitness or lifting but really it applies
to just about anything the place where
it's most often invoked is actually in
criticizing people who purport to be
psychics or people who just generally
make a lot of predictions about things
and then they hold up the predictions
they get right so but here's where that
breaks down a lot of things are
happening every day and if someone's
making a lot of predictions every day if
they make enough predictions they're
almost certain to hit the nail on the
head at least once or twice it would be
incredibly unlikely if if they didn't so
really when when people are talking
about oh like I predicted this
absolutely nailed it they probably got a
lot more things wrong so you can't
really put too much confidence in those
people who
to be psychics or claim to have great
predictive powers anyway so how this
relates to lifting fitness a lot of
times when people post videos before and
after photos big PRS they hit etc of
people people are kind of incredulous
you know they think it's either
impossible or just so unlikely to happen
that you know there has to be some sort
of foul play going on but when you stop
and think about it there's seven point
four ish billion people in the world you
know several million people are into
lifting fitness can't give you an exact
number but it's somewhere in the
millions so there's a lot of people
involved in it and that's a lot of
opportunities for anything to happen
even if you know let's say it has a one
in a million chance and there's three
million people who are lifting and
trying to do whatever thing this is man
I should have I should have run the
numbers before I use this as an example
but that would have probably like an
eighty to ninety percent chance of it
happening to at least one person every
year going back to that one in a
thousand example if that thing with a
one in a thousand chance of happening if
you gave it 10,000 opportunities for it
to happen instead of 1,000 those odds of
it occurring in one of those potential
opportunities goes from the 63.2% up to
99.9999 five or something like that so
at that point it's almost certain to
happen at least once and this this has
happened like say in lotteries where
there are six numbers that have to be
below 40 or 50 or whatever and in a few
one time in Bulgaria one time I think in
North Carolina yeah whatever
but within a span of three or four days
the same winning lottery numbers where
we're drawn like I said in the span of
like a week which that seems just
absolutely that seems incredibly in
but there are enough lottery drawings
going on
well there's lottery drawings for any
particular lottery all the time
there's lotteries going on around the
world all the time and I read an article
where the math who were some
mathematician ran the numbers and you
know he basically said that those draws
that occur in very close proximity to
each other we're the same winning
numbers are drawn where it seems like oh
like how could that happen by chance
basically it happens about as often as
you would expect it to just given the
odds of it happening in any one
opportunity but then also how many
opportunities there are for it to happen
so yeah this is just something generally
good to keep in mind when you see
something that seems amazing seems where
it makes you incredulous it you know
seems very unlikely to happen remember
you're thinking about that from your own
point of reference you're thinking what
are the odds that this would happen to
me that's kind of the tacit thought
process you have when really how you
should be thinking are what are the odds
that this could could potentially happen
to someone and if the odds of it
potentially being within the realm of
possibility as long as there's a nonzero
probability of it happening given enough
people and enough time it's almost
certain to happen eventually so yeah
that's about it for this video there is
going to be more content on this YouTube
channel coming up I'm working on trying
to upload three to four ish videos per
week we'll see if that actually happens
but that's the goal
so if you like this video it would be
stick around like the video subscribe to
the channel and hope you have a great
day
alright bye